also breaking at noon henry ruggs is not
going back to jail right now the former
las vegas raider was required to appear
in court this morning after missing an
alcohol test of course he's accused of
driving drunken causing that fiery crash
which killed 23 year old tina tintor
hector mejia explains why the judge did
not revoke his bail
in court this morning we learned henry
ruggs reportedly missed one alcohol test
due to the program running the
breathalyzer device not having his new
phone number did you notify
house arrest that you had in your
telephone number
okay so you should have
notified scram that you had a new
telephone number without that new phone
number an alert was not sent to the
handheld breathalyzer device called
scram ruggs walked into court monday as
his legal team explained they said
police had taken ruggs cell phone after
the crash scram program manager jennifer
rangel said his number became invalid
but besides that ruggs has been
compliant she's been extremely
cooperative prosecutors echoed the same
message saying ruggs has completed all
tests except for one during the hearing
we even heard an alert go off
his device is now going off he just told
me now that a cast is off ruggs can wear
an ankle device that monitors for
alcohol 24 hours a day it replaces the
handheld device he'll remain on house
arrest with no alcohol or driving
allowed i'm sure there will be a lot of
questions as to why
bill isn't revoked today because of one
missed
problem
as the statute
is written
it wouldn't allow me today to revoke
your bill i want to be very clear on
that i could increase your bail
i could hold you in contempt of court
and put you in custody for a few days
but i'm not going to do that hector
mejia reporting live local now
and ruggs has another court hearing
scheduled for next month